bis tief in die nacht wurde verhandelt
nun ist es amtlich bund und länder haben
eine verlängerung des schattens bis zum
18 april beschlossen über ostern gelten
strenge regeln und einschränkungen
willkommen zu unserem zdf live zum
aktuellen stand der dinge nachdem corona
gipfel
schön dass sie dabei sind und wir freuen
uns natürlich über eure kommentare und
fragen zu den beschlüssen und an unsere
experten und expertinnen ja zur
bekämpfung der ansteigenden zahlen soll
über ostern das öffentliche
wirtschaftliche und private leben
komplett oder stark heruntergefahren
werden wie nie zuvor in der krise es
gilt ein fünftägiger oster shutdown
bundeskanzlerin merkel und die
länderchefs und chefinnen haben für die
feiertage harte einschränkungen
beschlossen
doch nicht bei allen maßnahmen gab es
einigkeit und dazu ist uns unsere zdf
hauptstadtkorrespondenten andrea maurer
zugeschaltet die berichtet wieso sich
die verhandlungen so lange hingezogen
haben hallo andrea hallo berlin was war
denn die knackpunkte warum es sich so
lange hingezogen hat ja es waren
tatsächlich sehr lange verhandlungen
über elf stunden hat die runde
zusammengesessen in großen und den
kleinen runden muss man sagen also
kanzlerin ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten aber daneben
nach einer unterbrechung so gegen halb
sieben
auch die kanzlerin noch mal ein kleiner
runde mit olaf scholz markus söder und
michael müller und das zeigt auch wie
vertrag das war und das wohl tatsächlich
merkel auch den eindruck hatte dass es
in kleiner runde wahrscheinlich noch mal
deutlicher voran geht und sie soll diese
unterbrechung vor allem gefordert haben
weil sie eben auf keinen fall wollte
dass urlaub im eigenen bundesland
möglich ist was ja viele
ministerpräsidenten gefordert hatten
also dieser kontakt am urlaub auf
campingplätzen oder in ferienhäusern das
wollte merkel auf keinen fall
und sie wollte es auch nicht als
protokollnotiz im beschluss am ende
also das wäre auch noch eine möglichkeit
gewesen dass beispielsweise mecklenburg
vorpommern niedersachsen oder
schleswig-holstein in dem beschluss
vermerkt hätten dass sie das für ihr
bundesland dann sozusagen als
ausnahmeregelung haben wollten und das
ist sozusagen hat merkel gekippt auf
ihrer seite oder das hat das kanzleramt
sozusagen verhindert und die länder
wiederum haben wohl vom tisch genommen
dass das dass in schulen sozusagen bei
einer inzidenz über 100 dann nur dann
geöffnet werden kann wenn zwei mal pro
woche getestet werden das wollte wieder
um das kanzleramt
ja wir schauen mal kurz auf unserem
beitrag vielen dank andrea bis hierhin
wir kommen gleich nochmal zu dir zurück
wir schauen uns eine kurze eine kurze
zusammenfassung an was denn alles
beschlossen wurde hier ein beitrag von
ihnen und der schotter und wird
verlängert bis zum 18
april das war das einzige worauf sich
bund und länder schnell geeinigt hatten
doch um den rest wurde bis 2 uhr 33 in
der früh gestritten und gerungen großer
und ein kleiner runde
fest steht es gibt keine lockerungen zu
ostern im gegenteil wir haben eben dass
wir uns noch nicht besiegen können
es lässt nicht locker und zu haben bund
und länder eine erweiterte ruhezeit zu
ostern beschlossen vom ersten bis zum
fünften vierten konkret gelten
gründonnerstag und karsamstag
zusätzliche ruhetage wobei die
lebensmittelläden am samstag öffnen
dürfen treffen sind nur zwischen zwei
haus ständen erlaubt maximal fünf
personen kinder bis 14 jahre
nicht mitgezählt religiösen
versammlungen sollen virtuell
durchgeführt werden vom tisch damit der
kontakt arme urlaub in ferienhäusern und
auf campingplätzen wie ihn die
küstenländer planten eine generelle test
pflicht vor dem rückflug soll für alle
auslandsurlaub gelten auch wenn sie aus
nicht risikogebieten wie mallorca kommen
eine quarantäne pflicht steht nicht im
abschlusspapier
konsequent solle die bereits seit märz
beschlossene notbremse angewendet werden
dort wo die sieben tage incidents stabil
über 100 liegt bestehende lockerungen
zum beispiel im handel müssen dann
zurückgenommen werden
ausgangs beschränkungen werden nicht
vorgeschrieben aber können von den
landkreisen hat zusätzliche maßnahmen
ergriffen werden
insgesamt also eine ganz ernsthafte
konferenz auf der wir ein maßnahmenpaket
beschlossen haben das deutlich macht
dass wir in einer schwierigen phase der
pandemie sind mitten in der dritten
welle dass diese welle nicht zu hoch
werden darf damit wir auch die im
verfolge uns nicht gefährden nach ostern
soll eine phase umfangreicher tests
beginnen in bürgerzentren schulen kitas
und unternehmen all jene die auf mehr
lockerungen zu ostern hofften werden von
den beschlüssen dieser nacht enttäuscht
sein
und wieder wurde nur ein kapitel im
kampf gegen das virus geschrieben keine
langzeitstrategie am 12 april findet das
nächste bund länder treffen statt
ja wir haben uns gerade diese überblick
angehört was denn alles beschlossen
wurde andrea merkel spricht ja auch in
ihrer rede von einem kurzen aber
konsequenten phase des stillstands
was ist denn da so die meinung aus der
aus der politik ist das der ist dass das
was es was die zahlen sozusagen wieder
sinken lassen soll
wenn wir jetzt einfach stillstehen ja
also es in der in der bund länder runde
war es tatsächlich einigkeit dass das
ist diesen oster shutdown wohl braucht
es ist auch ganz interessant dass der
eigentlich gar nicht in den
beschlussvorlagen vorab stand sondern
dass der anscheinend in den
verhandlungen auf den tisch gekommen ist
diese fünf tage um die es da jetzt geht
und ansonsten in der opposition da hat
sich heute morgen christian lindner
schon auf twitter zu wort gemeldet und
der schrieb ja dass es eine
erschütternde konzeptlosigkeit sei die
er da eben sieht das sozusagen das
prinzip wir bleiben zu hause auch nach
einem jahr pandemie immer noch die
zentrale antwort auf die pandemie sein
sollte und er fragte auch wo sind denn
eigentlich die innovativen lösungen wie
zum beispiel in tübingen und das ist
natürlich diese stimmen gibt es auch ja
wir haben zum beispiel hier eine frage
von lucky girl gründonnerstag ist jetzt
ruhetag was heißt das denn für die
arbeitende bevölkerung ja also dieser
tag wird gehandelt würde ich sagen wie
ein feiertag also das heißt es wird
nicht gearbeitet
außer natürlich dass man meinte merkel
gestern auch nochmal beispielsweise
unternehmen die an sonntagen auch
arbeiten oder arbeitnehmer da wird es
wohl sonder regelungen geben es ist wohl
tatsächlich so dass sich die chefs der
staatskanzleien heute auch noch einmal
über die details tatsächlich besprechen
wollen eventuell auch heute abend noch
mal telefonieren wollen weil tatsächlich
da ein paar aspekte unklar sind klar ist
die lebensmittelläden werden
an diesem gründonnerstag zu sein die
haben tatsächlich dann nur an dem
ostersamstag auf außengastronomie ist
geschlossen es gibt ein
versammlungsverbot
es gibt kontakt beschränkungen im
haushalt also maximal zwei haushalte
zwei haushalte mit maximal fünf personen
sollen sich treffen dürfen und ja also
das so sollen diese fünf tage am stück
dann im grunde genommen so eine
entspannung in diesen steigenden
inzidenz infektionszahlen bringen die
tatsächlich und das war auch gestern
noch mal thema auch vermehrt junge
menschen treffen und und es zeichnet
sich eben auch ab dass die
intensivstation tatsächlich immer mehr
patienten jetzt auch behandeln müssen
es ist ja auch so dass wenn jetzt alles
geschlossen ist dann ist ja samstag
sozusagen geöffnet und das schreiben
auch kommentare auf youtube
das ist ja nicht eigentlich ist das
nicht eigentlich sinnlos sozusagen am
samstag die lebensmittelgeschäfte wieder
zu öffnen wenn dann da alle
wahrscheinlich ihre ostereinkäufe machen
wollen müssen und sich dann wieder
treffen ja also dazu haben wir
tatsächlich auch noch nichts von seiten
der politik gehört wie das vermieden
werden soll
das ist tatsächlich ein problem was auch
gesehen wird man muss dazu wissen
gestern bei dieser pressekonferenz die
fragen im anschluss die waren sehr
begrenzt also es war glaube ich noch mal
15 minuten dass journalistinnen und
journalisten da fragen stellen konnte
konnten das war natürlich auch der
urzeit geschuldet und der müdigkeit
aller beteiligten aber solche fragen
sind da tatsächlich im detail konnten
nicht geklärt werden und da ist es
vielleicht tatsächlich noch der müssen
wir den heutigen tag noch mal abwarten
ob es da tatsächlich auch eine
politische antwort auf diese sehr
berechtigte frage gibt gibt es denn
eigentlich von der politik auch noch
forderungen nach schärferen maßnahmen
denn eigentlich ist die inzidenz sei ja
jetzt steigt ja immer weiter die wir
sehen dass die zahlen steigen und es gab
ja nun mal auch von vielerlei aus der
politik zum beispiel spd-politiker
lauterbach der herforder dass wir sogar
noch schärfer schärfere maßnahmen
eigentlich durchsetzen müssen oder
wieder zurück gehen müssten
ob es da noch mal eine diskussion oder
wurde gesagt bis hierhin und nicht
weiter
na ja es gab ja auch im vorfeld die
diskussion um ausgangssperren dass das
eben auch noch mal ein mittel der wahl
sein könnte um weitere
infektionsgeschehen zu verhindern weil
das ja länder gibt wie beispielsweise
frankreich wo man wohl erfolge gesehen
hat diese ausgangssperren sind jetzt in
dem jetzigen beschluss nur einen
vorschlag also da heißt es wenn die
instanzen über 100 sind dann hat eben
ein landkreis die möglichkeit oder gibt
es die empfehlung dass man
beispielsweise wenn man gemeinsam auto
fährt und nicht einen hausstand angehört
dass man dann maske trägt es gibt die
empfehlung ausgangssperren aber das ist
eben keine wie soll ich sagen keine
pflicht sondern das sind vorschläge das
hat sich merkel gestern auch noch mal
gesagt also es könnte dann
möglicherweise wieder zu einem
sogenannten von dem wir schon oft gehört
haben flickenteppich kommen weil jedes
land sein eigenes ding dreht ja das also
diese möglichkeit besteht tatsächlich
das halt natürlich das dann nochmal
regional in den landkreisen gehandhabt
wird
was eben passiert wenn das ganze über
diese 100 geht und inwiefern da eben
dann die notbremse am trägt tatsächlich
ja was vielleicht auch noch mal
interessant ist es war ja auch vorab
noch die debatte um die verschärfung
beispielsweise beim thema mallorca
da hatte das auswärtige amt ja vor
einigen tagen oder kürzlich die
reisewarnungen aufgehoben und es gab mir
einen richtigen buchungs boom und da war
ja die frage ob man möglicherweise
touristinnen und touristen aus mallorca
verpflichten muss bei der rückkehr in
quarantäne zu gehen das ist vom tisch es
ist jetzt tatsächlich so dass die
fluggesellschaften verpflichtet sind bei
einreise also die rückkehrer sozusagen
zu testen aber diese quarantäne pflicht
jetzt für mallorca die gibt es nicht
also da gibt es keine verschärfung
ok also wissen wir dazu auch wenn ich
mir bescheid
vielleicht noch ein kommentar von nils
dice die wieso schafft man es nicht zwei
wochen einfach alles dicht zu machen
trautmann ist der bevölkerung nicht zu
oder geht es dann doch wieder um die
wirtschaft ja also ich kann sozusagen
nicht die frage beantworten warum sich
das niemand traut ich glaube einfach
dass es sei ein abwägungsprozess ist den
den politikerinnen und politiker
politiker hier treffen müssen ob der
jetzt richtig oder falsch ist das liegt
natürlich dann auch wieder im ermessen
aber sozusagen der shutdown für ein
ganzes land so würde ich sagen da dringt
gerade niemand durch weil natürlich auch
tatsächlich es wirtschaftliche
konsequenzen hätte wobei natürlich auch
der das was wir jetzt schon haben
wirtschaftliche konsequenzen hat
aber diese maximalforderung shutdown das
ganze land lahmlegen
die hat momentan würde ich sagen kein
politisches hat kein politisches
durchsetzungsvermögen
ok dann schauen wir was beim nächsten
corona gipfel nach ostern wie es dann
weitergeht
wir bleiben auf dem neuesten stand
vielen dank dass du den gipfel
beobachtet hass und vielen dank für
deine einschätzung bis hierhin danke dir
andrea denke die ja harter shutdown über
ostern ist natürlich die frage reichen
diese maßnahmen aus um die zahlen sinken
zu lassen
dazu ist natürlich auch die
wissenschaftliche seite interessant wie
sich diese zahlen dass diese kurve
entwickeln kann und darüber möchte ich
mit unserem experten und pharmazeuten
professor thorsten lehr von der uni
saarland sprechen
schön dass sie da sind hallo hallo herr
wunderschönen tag
sie haben mit ihrem team an der
universität das projekt kosten
geschaffen das ist ja so eine art kowitz
simulator mit dem sie auf grundlage
mathematischer modelle den aktuellen
verlauf der korona pandemie vorhersagen
können also ich würde jetzt mal
behaupten sie sind kein prophet aber was
bedeuten denn die aktuellen core oder
beschlüsse denn jetzt rechnerisch für ja
vor ostern
ja also das mit der vorhersage ist in
der tat ein bisschen schwierig in dem
fall weil was ihr euch jetzt entwickeln
wird hängt natürlich auch sehr stark
davon ab wie die bevölkerung eigentlich
diesen diese neuen maßnahmen endlich
umsetzen wird das ist immer das große
schwierigkeit auch in unseren modellen
lassen
dieser faktor mensch natürlich
unberechenbar ist und das können wir
auch gar nicht wirklich prognostizieren
wir können verschiedene szenarien
zeichnen und schauen was wir denn
erwarten würden wenn sich die
bevölkerung so verhallt verhält wie
beispielsweise anfang märz was wir
momentan sehen ist eigentlich dass die
entwicklung relativ dramatisches also
vor dem bund länder gibt es jetzt hier
waren die zahlen sehr stark steigend das
hatte natürlich zum einen damit zu tun
dass wir die neue variante haben aus
großbritannien die sich jetzt sehr stark
ausgebreitet hat wir haben uns über 75
prozent verbreitung deutschlandweit und
gleichzeitig noch den lockerungen anfang
märz von daher war es jetzt ganz wichtig
dass wir erstmal interveniert haben ob
die maßnahmen jetzt letztendlich reichen
das können wir gerne gleich noch mal
diskutieren für mich gehen sie nicht
weit genug aber wie gesagt das gerne
gleich noch im gespräch
was würden sie denn dann ändern wenn es
ihnen jetzt nicht weit genug reicht ja
also sind ja verschiedene dinge gerade
schon angeklungen wir haben jetzt
natürlich so eine art im roster mini
lockdown gleichzeitig können wir haben
uns letztendlich aber trotzdem an dem
samstag wieder einkaufen gehen das wäre
sicherlich sinnvoll gewesen die
geschäfte dazu zu lassen wir hatten so
ein ähnliches szenario beispielsweise
auch schon vor weihnachten wenn wir uns
noch erinnern wo denn die letzten
shopping einkäufe noch gemacht wurden
bevor die geschäfte zu gemacht haben so
was ähnliches kann man sicherlich an
diesem samstag auch erwarten
gleichzeitig haben natürlich immer noch
an ostern auch die möglichkeit dass wir
uns treffen diese treffen waren an
weihnachten schon keine gute idee dort
sind die infektionszahlen relativ
deutlich gestiegen auch wenn es
vielleicht in der gesamt abfallenden
kurve gar nicht so aufgefallen ist haben
wir teilweise zwischen 50 bis 100
prozent mehr kontakte gehabt über
weihnachten und neujahr und sowas
ähnliches erwarte ich jetzt auch und
gleichzeitig haben wir aber eben auch
noch diese neue britische variante die
deutliche infektiöser ist und wenn wir
die natürlich in die familien tragen
habe ich sehe ich eine große gefahr dass
dann auch wirklich komplette familien
sich infizieren und wir dann relativ
großes infektionsgeschehen auch über
ostern haben herbeiführen können
aber im unterschied zu weihnachten ist
ja ostern jetzt schon sehr
ich sag jetzt mal ruhig gelegt worden
oder wird ruhig gelegt also wird das
nicht vielleicht doch einen unterschied
machen ja die frage wird eben sein wie
stark halten sich die bürgerinnen und
bürger daran haben die gefahr ist halt
wirklich wenn sie sich nicht daran
halten dann haben wir mit dieser
variante jetzt natürlich die gefahr dass
dass es sich dort stark ausbreiten kann
da sind jetzt relativ viel unbekanntes
gilt vor allem daran auch an die
bürgerinnen und bürger zu appellieren
diese osterfeiertage eben auch
besinnlich zu genießen im kreise der
engsten familie und diese besucher nicht
auszuweiten und wenn wenn denn irgendwie
besucher nötig ist natürlich auch das
mittel des schnelltests einzusetzen dass
wir bis jetzt an weihnachten eben auch
noch nicht hatten also wir haben
sicherlich ein paar gute optionen jetzt
seine hand wir müssen sie halt eben nur
schlaue und effizienter möglich
einsetzen
es gibt da eine frage von vanessa eugen
die sagt bzw auch noch mehr so sind ein
kommentar vielleicht sogar dass die
büros immer noch auf sind weil da ja nur
empfehlungen und aufforderungen weil es
nur empfehlungen und aufforderungen gibt
also sie wünscht sich ein oder per
gesetz das den angestellten die
entscheidung selber überlassen wird also
das bezieht sich jetzt natürlich
persönlich nur auf ostern sondern ganz
allgemein aber wie sehen sie das sollte
das einfach wirklich per gesetz
durchgesetzt werden
home office ja also prinzipiell sind in
diesen ganzen beschlüssen noch sehr viel
freiwilligkeit und sehr viele beispiel
faktoren hätte kreativ viele
möglichkeiten offen lassen an das sehe
ich als großes problem das thema home
office ist eigentlich schon lange ein
großes thema wir haben jetzt in der
zweiten welle eigentlich gesehen dass
das mittel der haube des home office gar
nicht mehr so stark genutzt wurde und
wir wissen eben aus verschiedenen
berechnungen studien dass auch viele
infektionen eben am arbeitsplatz
stattfinden dass wir viele arbeitgeber
letztendlich trotzdem darauf drängen
dass dort letztendlich präsenz auch
ausgeübt wird das ist halt eben sehr
nachteil haft und ich würde mich schon
freuen wenn es der gesetzliche
verpflichtungen geben würde auch dass
dem arbeitnehmer letztendlich zu
überlassen das könnte sicherlich helfen
zum einen die mobilität einzuschränken
weil diese infektion finden ja auch
nicht normal arbeitsplatz statt
viele bürgerinnen
wir müssen eben auch mit öffentlichen
personennahverkehr dorthin reisen und
das würde natürlich auch noch quasi
wegstrecke nehmen und infektions
möglichkeiten von daher würde ich das
persönlich sehr begrüßen ja sie haben ja
wir haben hier eine grafik von ihnen
vorliegen die die sie uns mitgebracht
haben ich hoffe wir sehen die gleich
auch im stream
worüber wir vielleicht reden können wir
sie da anhand so jetzt müsste man sie
sehen genau wo man anhand ihrer jahr
berechnungen sehen kann was sie ja auch
schon erwähnt haben wenn jetzt passiert
keine änderungen
die notbremse von der auch in den
beschlüssen oder in der pressekonferenz
gesprochen wurde und zusätzliche
maßnahmen
was würde das denn jetzt für sie
bedeuten diese zusätzlichen maßnahmen
die scheinbar so sieht das nach dieser
grafik aus die zahlen wieder sehr extrem
sinken lassen sollen
ja genau also wir sehen ja erstmal drei
kurven vielleicht ganz kurz die die
etwas bläuliche tore die wir gesehen
haben genau war letztendlich der
anschuldigung sonst damit wir auch alle
sehen die bläuliche kurve die sehr steil
nach oben geht es letztendlich was würde
mit der inzidenz passieren wenn wir
jetzt nichts machen würden ich finde es
immer wichtig dass man zu zeigen
es wird sehr oft kritisiert dass das
heißt die einzige dessen von 500 das ist
richtig so würde es nicht kommen die
bevölkerung wurde natürlich dort
eingreifen die politik würde eingreifen
trotzdem ist es wichtig zu sehen dass
wir gerade in einem sehr steilen anstieg
uns befinden deswegen ist es wichtig
dass man zu verdeutlichen
und wie gesagt das liegt in unserer hand
die notbremse ist letztendlich jetzt so
das wir annehmen okay durch die
notbremse würden wir erreichen was wir
anfang märz hatten also das heißt wieder
eine rücknahme von vielen kontakten
was wir aber da schon sehen ist dass es
möglicherweise nicht ausreicht weil die
maßnahmen jetzt durch die mutante die
eben anfang märz auch nur bei knapp
unter 50 prozent lag und jetzt deutlich
über 75 jetzt viel mehr zum
infektionsgeschehen beiträgt und
deswegen kann es hier gut sein dass das
eben nicht ausreicht diese rein
notbremsen maßnahmen vor allem weil so
viele freiwilligkeit natürlich auch noch
mit drin ist
wir haben deshalb auch gestern dann noch
mal überlegt zusätzliche maßnahmen wie
zum beispiel ausgangssperre sind ja auch
noch ein freiwilliges mittel wie es ja
schon gerade geheißen hat aber da wissen
wir tatsächlich gar nicht so richtig wie
viel bringt das wir wissen aus studien
beispielsweise auch aus amerika dass das
so als ein on top also zusätzlich auf
existierenden maßnahmen noch mal so um
die 20 prozent reduktion von kontakten
bringen kann
es könnte aber natürlich auch noch durch
andere maßnahmen erreicht werden wie zum
beispiel indem man auch beispielsweise
die schulen wieder schließt auch da
sehen wir das ist ein einfluss auf
infektionsgeschehen hat aber bei vielen
dingen müssen wir auch gar nicht so
richtig welchen effekt sie eigentlich
haben und das ist natürlich das
bedauerliche nach einem jahr pandemie
sind wir immer noch sehr ratlos ist
dieser maßnahmen angeht es sind dort
keine wirklichen studien großartig
gelaufen deutschlandweit wo man sich
eben bemüht hat mal das rauszukriegen
das ist finde ich ein großes versäumnis
was auch diese öffnung und schließung
eben in einem großen zufallsprinzip
gleichen lässt sie sagen ja auch dass
die große unbekannte in der berechnung
das verhalten der bürgerinnen und bürger
sei also was jetzt auch gerade erwähnt
haben das sozusagen eigentlich die
infektion innerhalb der familien
stattfinden und gar nicht jetzt
unbedingt vielleicht im öffentlichen
raum
was meinen sie damit genau er genau also
dass das das große das also das große
problem ist erstmal dass die das
überhaupt das also wir dürfen aber nicht
vergessen in dieser infektion des
infektionsgeschehen ist natürlich durch
uns getrieben wir sind letztendlich der
verbreiter und auch der empfänger dieses
virus des virus kann ohne uns
letztendlich nicht existieren und sich
nicht vermehren
das heißt wir sind diejenigen die diese
infektion treiben und haben das halten
natürlich diese infektion noch in der
hand das müssen wir uns immer wieder vor
augen führen und dürfen das letztendlich
nicht auf höhere mächte oder irgendwas
geben wir sind hier sehr stark auch in
der möglichkeit es zu steuern
aber was wir jetzt haben ist eben auch
diese diese unberechenbarkeit der
bevölkerung gesehen eben oft verhalten
dass wenn wir sehr hohe infektionszahlen
haben sehr hohes infektionsgeschehen
dass die bevölkerung sich auch für mehr
zurücknimmt
das heißt also das haben wir auch
gesehen dass beispielsweise maßnahmen
schon gegriffen haben als es nur
ankündigung von der
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz zum
beispiel gehabt dass ich leute schon
zurückgenommen haben ohne dass die
beschlüsse durchgesetzt wurden dass er
irgendwann dieser maßnahmen dann auch
wir greifen das haben wir beispielsweise
jetzt anfang februar gesehen dass leute
dann plötzlich mehr kontakte hatten weil
sie pandemie des entwicklers heute
neudeutsch so schön heißt das heißt
einfach die möglichkeit einfach vorher
stand den maßnahmen nicht mehr folge
geleistet wird das sehen wir dann oft
wenn natürlich die maßnahmen wenn die
infektionszahlen niedrig sind dass wir
jetzt aber bedenken müssen jetzt eben
mit dieser neuen mutante haben wir jetzt
eine röhre infektiosität und die wird
eben oft auch in die familien
reingetragen und das sehe ich halt
jemals eine gewisse gefahr jetzt auch
für ostern eben für die feierlichkeiten
dass ich dann diese infektion in der
ganzen familie ausbreiten und da müssen
wir eben schauen dass wir das halt
möglichst wirklich unterbinden ja sie
haben ja auch gesagt oder sie haben auch
schon angesprochen dass das natürlich
über die schnelltests gut funktionieren
kann
jetzt habe ich ja einen kommentar von
colo colo weiter von aus youtube
er sagt bei der verkündeten öffnungs
strategie war das deutlich erhöhte
testen bekannt ich meine er fragt jetzt
natürlich was sagt die bundesregierung
zum verhältnis incidents und testen
steigende zahlen waren ja zu erwarten
also im grunde was sagen sie jetzt dazu
müssen wir jetzt einfach weiter testen
im strategie weiter ausbauen sind die
maßnahmen jetzt wirklich so sinnvoll
oder sollten wir einfach eigentlich an
der anderen baustelle weitermachen
na ja wir haben ziemlich viele
baustellen die wir haben das sind
nämlich schon in den berliner flughafen
hier haben dass ich hoffe nur dass es
ein bisschen besser und schneller endet
dass das testen ist in meinen augen auch
ein großes großes problem also die
schnelltest an sich sind tolle mittel
das möchte ich gar nicht absprechen aber
wenn man das große problem wir schmeißen
sie quasi auf die bevölkerung und
kriegen eigentlich überhaupt kein
feedback wie viel positive test zu haben
wie viel negativer tests haben deswegen
können wir momentan bei den zahlen
eigentlich gar nicht genau sagen wie
viel prozent dieser instanzen eigentlich
zurückzuführen sind auf die schnelltest
ich würde sehr begrüßen wenn das
robert-koch-institut oder die
gesundheitsämter erstmal auch erheben
werden würden wie viele dieser tests der
positiven pcr-test eben auch auf
positive schnellte so zu finden sind
dann hätte man eine gewisse ratio wenn
ich eben weil ich meinen 10.000 positive
fälle hätte und davon werden 9000 von
positiven schnelltest würde ich das als
ein sehr gutes zeichen sehen weil dann
hätte ich sehr viele dunkelziffer fälle
aufgeklärt
auf der anderen seite aber das wissen
wir halt leider nicht genauso wenig
wissen wir einfach aus den schulen weil
das überhaupt nicht systematisch erhoben
wird und auch in keinster weise
evaluiert wird
das ist für mich ein großes versäumnis
so steigen die zahlen es gibt
verschiedene vermutungen und die teile
ich auch dass sie eigentlich gar keinen
so großen effekt momentan haben auf das
infektionsgeschehen man geht also
vielleicht zwischen 10 und 20 prozent
aus von den zahlen die erhöht werden und
das würde ich momentan auch in etwa
unterschreiben aber es ist sehr
schwierig weil die fallzahlen fehlen das
zu untermauern und andererseits müssen
wir natürlich und das ist auch ganz
wichtig wir dürfen nicht vergessen die
impfstrategie ist natürlich eine ganz
wichtige und die krank natürlich auch
noch an allen ecken und enden wir impfen
immer noch extrem langsam wie hamburg
knapp 25 prozent der über 70-jährigen
geimpft wir müssen momentan und mit
einer million bürgerinnen und bürger pro
woche das ist einfach viel zu wenig um
wirklich hier auch aus diesen diesen
kritischen zahlen raus zu kommen
die inzidenz irgendwie in den griff zu
bekommen da gibt es auch eine frage von
9000 warum können die nicht nicht
einfach mehrere produktionen für den
impfstoff machen also warum kann ich
einfach viel viel mehr impfstoff
produziert werden und an alle verteilt
werden na gut das problem ist natürlich
dass wir eine gewisse kapazität brauchen
dieser impfstoff ist natürlich sehr
komplex herzustellen das ist jetzt
leider nicht irgendwie wie ein brötchen
oder so was irgendwo in jeder ecke von
eltern bekommen da brauchen sie komplexe
produktionsanlagen die abgenommen werden
müssen
vor allem die modernen impfstoffe sind
eben auch kompliziert herzustellen
die kapazitäten eben baut man nicht von
jetzt auf gleich auf wir haben das eine
diskussion vom montag in marburg gesehen
da ist natürlich viel behördliche
abnahme um auch notwendig und das ist
auch richtig weil wir eben auch keine
verunreinigung wollen wir geben diese
substanzen direkt quasi in den körper
über der nadel das heißt verunreinigung
und prozesse die nicht richtig ablaufen
können auch sehr schnell großes problem
abbilden wenn dann chargen verunreinigt
sind
also das heißt diese skalierung
funktioniert nicht die skalierung hätte
man dann vorantreiben können wenn man im
sommer letzten jahres letztendlich viel
mehr bestellt hätte dann hätten die
firmen vorher die produktionskapazitäten
hochfahren können aber herr der eu
natürlich sehr stark auf das geld
geschaut und natürlich dauer kosten
versucht zu optimieren und in meinen
augen nicht ausreichend impfstoff
bestellt als das jetzt die kapazitäten
ausreichen würden
wir müssen aber schauen dass wir
wirklich langfristig auch diese
kapazitäten nach oben behalten das heißt
produktionskapazität nomaden weil ich
schon befürchtet dass wir auch
vielleicht im herbst oder winter noch
mal eine neue mutante bekommen können
wir dann entsprechende bevölkerung auch
noch mal nach hessen müssen also sie
vermuten schon dass zum beispiel jetzt
auch weil wir ja noch oft sagen dass
jetzt im frühjahr wenn es jetzt wärmer
wird dass es weil die dieser virus ja
auch vielleicht saisonal ist und
sozusagen auch vielleicht sich
eigentlich absprechen sollte aber nun
steigen die zahlen jetzt wieder was
denken sie denn wie es jetzt weiter geht
ja also diese saisonalität wird den
corona wir natürlich nachgesagt auch
diesen satz 2 virus haben aber
letztendlich und das dürfen wir nicht
vergessen in der ersten welle die
eigentlich ziemlich genau vor einem jahr
geschehen ist genau das gleiche gesehen
da war es draußen eigentlich sehr schön
aber trotzdem sind die zahlen
angestiegen das heißt die saisonalität
spielten kleinen teil in diesem
orchester aber sie spielt letztendlich
nicht die erste geige das dürfen wir
nicht vergessen also darauf allein
dürfen uns nicht beruhen und auch im
sommer hatten wir infektionen und das
infektionsgeschehen ist angeheizt
das heißt wir können wir vielleicht eine
leichte entspannung erwarten wir können
vielleicht auch möglichkeiten sehen wie
beispielsweise außengastronomie zu
öffnen oder ähnliches aber wir dürfen
nicht vergessen dass das eigentlich im
letzten jahr gar nicht so gut
funktioniert hat wir uns immer wieder
einreden
das heißt also hier ist für mich
eigentlich die einzige möglichkeit wie
wir rauskommen ist zum einen dass sie
einfach auf die impfstrategie hoffen
beziehungsweise offen dass die impfung
vermehrt auftauchen wird also wenn wir
ungefähr mit vier millionen impfungen
pro woche inseln würden wir uns
natürlich schon sehr geholfen dann würde
würden wir nach unseren berechnungen
auch dagegen sommer schon auch eine
deutliche entspannung sehen das heißt es
jetzt einfach erst mal die zähne
zusammenzubeißen und durchzuhalten
wir dürfen immer wieder nicht vergessen
wir haben den impfstoff der see oder wir
haben mehrere impfstoffe die sehr
effizient sind es kommen auch noch
verschiedene auf den markt dass ich hier
kann sich auch noch durch zum beispiel
zulassung von sputnik oder johnson
johnson oder auch hier wirkt natürlich
noch einiges ändern auch da sind
kapazitäten noch vorhanden
ich denke das ist schon kommt es kommt
immer wieder dieses dieses beispiel der
ketchup flasche weiß ich gar nicht mag
habe das problem der ketchup flaschen
analogie ist dass es am anfang langsam
und zum schluss schnell kommt ist die
voraussetzung dass erstmal die flasche
voll ist die flasche ist aber momentan
nicht voll und deswegen quietschen dinge
in sachen jedes ketchup tröpfchen raus
was wir haben
und das ist halt das problem dass wir
mal eine neue flasche bräuchten und die
die sehe ich jetzt noch nicht aber ich
hoffe dass sie eben gerade gefüllt wird
es wird auch noch gefragt vielleicht
können sie dazu noch eine diese eine
frage beantworten von la vie sie 93 das
ist ja auch schon ein thema was in den
letzten wochen durch die ganzen medien
geht natürlich sollten hausärzte
hausärztinnen nicht so schnell wie
möglich also am besten eigentlich ab
morgen impfen können
der absolute ist es in meinen augen auch
eine der wichtigen haben ja elemente
dadurch dass wir schnell impfen können
die hausärzte kennen letztendlich ihre
ihre ihre patienten und patientinnen und
das ist natürlich ganz wichtig da gibt
es viele differenzierungen die auch wo
ich jetzt findet dass diese
priorisierung natürlich vielleicht nicht
ganz sinnvoll ist wo dann teilweise ja
71-jährige gesunde patienten geimpft
werden aber ein 69 jähriger mit einer
nierenschaden zum beispiel nicht geben
würde obwohl das risiko laut viel größer
ist also ich sehe auf jeden fall in der
fläche eine sehr gute möglichkeit das
auszubreiten
aber der impfstoff ist momentan das
große die große große flaschenhals der
einfach nicht verfügbar ist und wenn wir
letztendlich dann nur pro haus als
vielleicht zehn impfungen haben dann
wird die frustration auch relativ
schnell der groß sein
deswegen glaube ich brauche mir das erst
mal der fläche die ärztinnen und ärzte
sind bereit und das ist super und ich
glaube sobald der impfstoff dann da als
muss es unbedingt über die ärzte und
ärztin in die flächigen dann vielen dank
für ihre einschätzungen herr professor
lehr und wir schauen mal wie es dann
nach ostern aussieht und vielleicht
sprechen wir uns dann wieder vielen dank
ich dagegen
ja das war unser zdf heute live zum
aktuellen stand nachdem corona beschluss
wir bleiben natürlich weiter für sie
dran und informieren sie über den
aktuellen stand der dinge und hoffen
dass sie dann auch wieder dabei sind
vielen dank und bis bald